a lot of excitement this morning
everyone is excited because
ronnie the limo driver is going to be
hypnotized
and round two of ronnie gets hypnotized
we did this a couple of years ago
and ronnie came in his pants that's
right keep talking to her keep telling
her what to do
yeah oh boy
oh no
i gotta go
[Music]
anyway ronnie is way more fun hypnotized
than he is as a normal human being my
goodness
i see ronnie on camera he's very relaxed
already you've been working with him all
morning right
he's got everything registering in his
head right now so i have
asked scott to hypnotize ronnie
so that when i say the word nascar
ronnie is going to feel like he's
getting pegged in the ass
all right all right hey ron how you
feeling you i heard you were pretty
relaxed from the hypnotism
yeah i'm just curious did you watch
nascar
this weekend yeah of course they did
nascar dude what's wrong
[ __ ] are you doing man what do you mean
what am i doing i didn't do anything
i just asked you about nascar my ass
hurts your ass hurts what are you
talking about what did you watch
ronnie what did you watch on nascar
can you describe what's going on right
now because i have no clue what's going
on i don't know it feels like
something's going on my ass i don't know
what happens if you say it really fast
you know ronnie everything with you is
nascar nascar nas karnaz car nascar
everything with you i gotta go
[Laughter]
you can't sit what's the matter with you
so
you don't want to talk about nascar oh
my god what are you doing
don't [ __ ] your pants what's going on
with your ass everything we do is
pegging in nascar i don't know what's
going on
i don't know what's going on sit down
and talk to me you can't be standing up
like that i mean all we're doing is
talking about nascar
all right
what are you laughing about
buddy what's going on you gotta tell me
i don't understand
you're laughing just going up my ass man
what the [ __ ]
what what are you doing i'm not doing
anything
no ronnie nascar is something i'm not
familiar with
there's nobody behind you i don't know
what you're looking at we're all set
up what's wrong ronnie you've always
wanted me to relate to you
about the automotive industry and stuff
and now i'm talking nascar in your act
itself
talk rumble what happened at
nasca nascar
[Laughter]
oh put him back on this whole weekend
go on to the next thing all right why
don't you sit back in the chair and
relax
close your eyes and go back into that
deep hypnotic state you were in before
i see [ __ ]
and go even deeper just go deeper and
wherever he went there was [ __ ] there
so i want you to go
into your mind right now and you've
always had this idea that
you wanted to experience life as a woman
so i want you to imagine yourself right
now as this
beautiful hot smoking hot woman
you are every man's desire
and in a moment i'm gonna count from one
to three
and when i reach the count of three
you'll open your eyes you're gonna be
that smoking hot woman you've always
wanted to be
and you are going to honestly evaluate
some of the male staff some of them
you're very attracted to one
two three open your eyes
hi what is your name
angelina angelina that is a sexy name i
gotta tell you you're one of the hottest
women i've ever seen how old are you
32 32 how big are your boobs if you
don't mind me asking
i i haven't measured them lately what
kind of bra do you wear or you don't
wear a bra
nah i don't wear a bra do guys come on
to you all day as hot as you are i like
i like my nipples to show through my
shirt do you wear panties
songs songs thongs
what color thong are you wearing today
black
you know the guys on my show right yes
of course whose brains would you
[ __ ] the hell out of hmm you could have
any of the guys
john heim nah he's a big boy
[Music]
you mean he's fat no he's just big big
dude she's like gorilla man oh right
like i'm afraid he's gonna like rip me
apart you know
is your vagina super tight is that what
you're saying oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah who's the guy on the
staff you really want to [ __ ] tell me
what you do to him
you [ __ ] smoking hot who is smoking
hot
who is it mike perlman mike perlman
he's got shot he got shot he's right by
that
yeah he's a bad boy you know look at
jalen how are you
how are you angelina i'm good how are
you you've been to the tanning parlor
lately
no no you always say that but no you
look so tan
no you're afraid of me aren't you i can
tell
you're afraid of me okay mike show
angelina your bullet scars that turns
her on go ahead look at this
look at this that's where he got shot i
can't tell you what i would do to that
all right listen mike just know
angelina's available
if you want to get your brains [ __ ]
out okay keep that in mind
and then this will i would [ __ ] will
hard
hard because he needs it bad he needs a
good [ __ ]
that's what he needs yeah because he
seems to me to be kind of like a sad
sack
but when he gets drunk oh my god watch
out he's like dr jekyll and mr hyde
angelina here's will right now look hey
hi angelina
hey how are you how are you
having a weekend with me and you
and another chick how's that i like it
nice one of us sucks dick the other
one's sucking on your balls
you have a friend in mind i have a
friend you know is she as hot as you
oh yeah lucky me oh
we would blow you unloads you would pass
out after we were done with you
yeah well that's what you need you need
your pipes cleaned hey uh scott can you
hypnotize will real quick and make this
happen
hey angelina now i'm getting turned on
who's gina j.d
i don't think you'd [ __ ] jd i really
don't see jd's the type that
you get locked up with ah so you won't
[ __ ] jd
or jd you [ __ ] him once and that's it
you're locked into this he probably
wouldn't let you out of the house
i'm gonna have a lot of fun angelina
stop it come on now hey jd
you would you could you couldn't get
angelina
you wouldn't know what to do with him
are you kidding me
how long would jd last in bed with you
two pumps and he'd be done
he might not even make it all the way
[Laughter]
she's so hot i mean yeah it's
understandable chris wilding thinks jd
has a big dick
what do you think i've heard stories
that's the biggest dick in the office no
it's not jd's whose is it who is it
jason kaplan did you [ __ ] him
good for him he supposedly has a [ __ ]
like an elephant
he's got a body like an elephant jason
how big is your [ __ ] tell angelina i
don't want to ruin this fantasy i i've
been enjoying this
yeah you're turning red i am a little
look at you
i didn't know you thought about my [ __ ]
before i didn't know that was first
i didn't know there was a thing i i'm
surprised i'm in your thoughts that's
all i'm
angelina you have an effect on men look
at this guy's beat red yeah it looks
like a beat
it's been a long time since someone
talked nicely about my [ __ ]
angelina benji says he would kiss you a
lot
benji go ahead real quick hi benji
hey how are you you're just so [ __ ]
beautiful
and i just want to [ __ ] kiss you so
[ __ ] badly
i could tell by those puffy eyes how
gentle you would be
i want to [ __ ] kiss your neck right
now so bad i know
i know you do and just no i want to grab
them under your hair
my [ __ ] is dripping for you as we speak
even by the way you talk
i'm looking at you now i just felt a
drop of your weapon
you're so [ __ ] wet right keep
thinking about my [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
i'm gonna put my hand down your legs
keep thinking about it
you like the way my hand feels on your
legs yeah
think about my [ __ ] too you want me
to listen fred call the cops
pick up both of them benji would think
are you thinking about angelina's
[ __ ] look at her ass
do you want my tongue in there oh yeah
you want me to like you
sure you feel that
you like the way that feels yeah is
benchy hypnotized too i'm losing trash
all right thank you benji i'm gonna
throw up all right benji
and angelino the new hot couple boy you
two are hot together i didn't know
angelina thank you a pleasure talking to
you you're one of the hottest girls i've
ever met thank you
thank you thank you for having me nascar
[Laughter]
[Music]